hello there guys we have some huge news
regarding the third Deadpool film with a
release date and confirmation that
Wolverine will show up in this film now
this was officially confirmed by Ryan
Reynolds hey Hugh you want to play
Wolverine one more time yeah sure and
the release date for this film is
September to 6 2024 so we have about two
years until we see this film so a bit of
a wait but honestly I'm really excited
for this film now this will be
Deadpool's first official appearance in
the MCU now everyone's probably
wondering in what capacity woohoo
Jackman's Wolverine be in this film and
I reckon he'll actually play a big role
because of two reasons the logo for the
film and that they have announced them
like having his Wolverine claws across
the Deadpool logo signifies that he will
play a large part in this film and the
fact that they even announced him
because we know for Spider-Man no way
home tobium Maguire and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man was not officially confirmed
until the release of the film it was
kept a surprise and they still had a
decent amount of screen time but for
Deadpool 3 they announced Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine ahead of the film's release
and I reckon they're doing this because
he will play a large part but either way
this is extremely exciting news because
I did not think we would see Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine again and this makes
me believe that the rumors of him
showing up as Wolverine in Avengers
Secret Wars is going to be true but let
me know your guys thoughts in the
comment section below and if you did
enjoy this video please like And
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching